rowdy's album
you know one of the biggest albums of
the last 10 years
the box is one of the biggest yeah is
the is
when roddy did the box did he go back in
and add the e like like
no he had that from jump so that was
already in there i was already in there
when you heard like he did that like
when he recorded like roddy does
voices and a lot of his songs that
people are going to start realizing
as far as like when he keeps more music
out but he's always
he always does [ __ ] like that that was
like his idea that wasn't a part of the
beat
absolutely no it was not part of the
beat it was alrighty's idea it's funny
because i was um
i was in hawaii on my honeymoon when the
album came out and that was the record i
remember
everybody was talking about i forget
which record was a big feature on it
but i remember telling dj amen like bro
i'm in hawaii
riding around in a convertible this this
the box [ __ ] is the one bro like
it's so crazy because that was like one
of the last two records he recorded
before he turned in his project so we
already had a
a roll out plan with everything besides
the box
damn that's why the video took so long
to get out
it's crazy because i haven't seen an
artist
besides i think kendrick's damn record
as far as like
songs that just ran radio for as long
like
high fashion ballin the bot like these
records are still like in power rotation
in radio stations
absolutely it's like they research like
it's it's insane bro it's
it's it's crazy uh
i mean he's been teasing this new feed
the street [ __ ] is that what is that
what's next
i hope so you hope so how much how many
records are you sitting on
at least a hundred a hundred at least
rodney does like five songs a day
it's crazy yeah he he makes so much
music like rodney could
he walk in right now set up a studio
right here and make 10 songs
that [ __ ] is on this table yeah it's
it's it's it's he's like one of those
you know i i tell people there's a few
artists
that it's hard for them to make a bad
song yeah you know i feel like roddy's
like
[ __ ] like you listen to all his [ __ ]
like it's like hard for
i feel like post malone's one of those
guys where like there might be some post
malone songs you might not [ __ ] with
but it's hard for postman to make a
shitty song like roddy rich
like roddy is one of them artists who's
like just his melodies are so
crazy like the way he can float on a
verse
nah he's special he's he's he's
definitely you know like he's like one
of those artists that come around every
10 years
100 yeah